thirty years ago the AMEX declared war
overwatch was created to rescue humanity
from the object crisis we became the
greatest champions of peace and progress
mankind has ever seen everybody knows
overwatch got shut down half of immerges
mercenaries now the people decided they
were better off without us they even
called us criminals they tore our family
apart Papa told me after so many years
of service
you gave overwatch everything and then
they pushed you out real life it's not
like the stories our father told us
you're a fool for believing it so
perhaps I am a fool to think there is
still hope for you brother
human-machine before me I see the future
humans and all necks standing together
the second Dominic crisis continues the
conflict between our necks and humans
has now claimed over 15,000 lives if you
do end someone has to do something
we have to do something always remember
never accept the world as it appears to
be dare to see it for what it could be
[Music]
this this is broadcasting on the
overwatch emergency frequency
I got a car they're getting the band
back together
they want me but really they need you I
have been cold
I must answer all where the enemy is out
there
getting stronger
the world is changing once again and
it's time to pick a side we can make a
difference again the world needs us now
more than ever are you with me yes I am
with you
you
[Music]